[Aplausos]
un gran amigo mío un querido colega
chabuco dice yo hasta ahora me estoy
entendiendo y ustedes quieren que me
reinventé no me jodan y creo que todos
nos sentimos un poco así este concepto
de reinvención que está tan de moda para
la muestra en la que estamos es un
concepto confuso muchas veces estamos
poco cansados de oírlo pero
definitivamente es un concepto que supo
una dinámica supone acomodarse supone
crecer supone aprender incluso supone
desaprender que es otro de esos
conceptos confusos y también a veces
hasta antipático pero que resulta muy
útil en este momento en que se están
viendo redadas las bases las estructuras
sobre las cuales inventamos nuestra
interacción con nosotros mismos con
nuestros semejantes y con nuestro con
nuestro entorno
los seres humanos vivimos ese proceso
día a día hasta unos nuevos tonos de
ahora porque somos seres estáticos somos
seres en constante evolución por más que
no lo sintamos por más que lo neguemos o
lo rechazamos
nos estamos adaptando permanentemente a
las circunstancias en mi caso por
ejemplo ha sido de estudiante de
finanzas y practicante en una
multinacional de telecomunicaciones a
cantante de bar de cantante es lars
dueño de bar artista independiente de
adicto al alcohol y las drogas adicto
rehabilitado en recuperación
de artista independiente a artista
firmado por una disquera y ahora de
artista firmado por una izquierda de
nuevo artista independiente y en este
camino siempre he tratado de seguir una
carta de navegación tengo tatuadas en mi
hombro izquierdo acá tres palabras que
para mí son esa carta de navegación y
que trato de regir mi vida a través de
ellas que son constancia equilibrio y
coherencia
la constancia es un concepto que bordea
la terquedad yo recuerdo que cuando le
mostré mi segundo disco un querido amigo
después de que el primero había tenido
un éxito apenas modesto me dice con su
marcado acento cartagenero me dice no
jodas anti tú si eres texto y es que
cuando las cosas salen mal después de
muchos intentos la gente dice que uno es
terco pero cuando las cosas salen bien
después de esos intentos la gente dice
que uno es constante verdad
el equilibrio el equilibrio yo realmente
no sé qué es según mi madre era la
palabra favorita de mi abuelo materno
julio entiendo que es una búsqueda es un
concepto dinámico y vuelve la palabra
porque además entre otras cosas para
montar en bicicleta por ejemplo y
mantener el equilibrio para caminar en
la cuerda floja y mantener el equilibrio
hay que estar en constante movimiento
verdad al final lo que yo creo o por lo
menos lo que entiendo de equilibrio en
mi caso es estar en paz con el precio
que uno paga porque todo tiene un precio
todo tiene un precio la idea es que ese
precio que no paga no sea tan costoso no
sea tan alto que implique el deterioro
de otros frentes de la vida porque oímos
permanentemente gente que dice que tal o
cual por enfocarse en su carrera a full
sacrifico su familia verdad pero
ejemplos
hay varios al respecto
y la coherencia dicen que el diccionario
dice más o menos que es como que tus
pensamientos se ven reflejados en tus
acciones
verdad también tengo claro que no es un
concepto estático es un concepto
dinámico no está grabado en piedra si
uno ve la vida de alguien en distintos
puntos puede incluso ser contradictorio
pero en cada punto está siendo coherente
porque vamos evolucionando porque vamos
cambiando ciertamente lo que yo pensaba
hace 20 años puede que ya no me
represente y lo sienta alejado a quién
soy yo ahora de hecho tengo canciones
que escrito hace años que ya no me
representan ya no me representan perdón
y me cuesta un montón ponerme en ese
lugar para interpretarlas así que los
voy dejando al lado en aquel momento
defenderlas sustentarlas era coherente
con quién era yo apartarlas ahora es
coherente con quién soy yo en este
momento aferrarse a una imagen propia
estática a una imagen estática del ser y
no aceptarse como un intento permanente
nos impide fluir como tenemos que fluir
en cualquier proceso de cambio y
ciertamente estamos en un proceso de
cambio así que para mí el aprendizaje
la evolución la adaptación la
reinvención se basa en esos tres pilares
fundamentales constancia equilibrio y
coherencia ahora no las tengo tanto
hacen ninguna parte pero también les
sumaría la intuición y la aceptación
para entrar un poco en lo que yo hago en
el mundo de la música siempre se habla
de lo que se oye o lo que se vende y se
quieren encausar los procesos creativos
hacia estas vertientes para facturar la
mayor cantidad de tiempo de dinero
posible
pasando por encima de la de la identidad
artística de muchas personas me pasó a
mí al principio de mi carrera con el
tropipop y me sigue pasando ahora con lo
urbano no muchas veces nos quieren
llevar a todos hacia el mismo lugar
cuando mi identidad artística le ha ido
forjando a través de los años es verdad
matizándola con sonidos nuevos con una
exploración estilística pero siempre
intentando ser fiel a quién soy yo como
artista mi reinvención mi adaptación y
evolución han tenido que ver siempre con
oírme con tener claro quién soy con
seguir mi intuición y ser cada vez más
consecuente con lo que hago verdad y eso
es clave o irse ahí es donde entra jugar
la intuición lo que pasa es que no
sabemos oírnos no no construimos
espacios para oírnos o dimos todo lo que
pasa a nuestro alrededor hay mucho ruido
a nuestro alrededor pero no buscamos los
espacios para oírnos y ahí es donde
están las respuestas en ese en ese hueco
en el estómago en ese dolor en las
entrañas en ese pecho que se va
volviendo pequeño cuando llega el
momento de la verdad
y ahí ahí hay muchas muchas respuestas a
través de la intuición entendido por
ejemplo que en mi carrera lo que quiero
es estar en la tendencia y no en la moda
me alimento de lo que suena oigo cosas
nuevas de todos los géneros identifico
los sonidos que me gusta de cada cosa y
me lo guardo para mí la moda tiene fecha
de caducidad la tendencia cambia muta
como el ser humano se reinventa he
trabajado con muchos productores a lo
largo de mi carrera muy experimentados
que en su momento me han ayudado a
moldear quién soy como artista y ahora
que lo sé en este nuevo proyecto en el
que estoy de nuevo como artista
independiente me he querido rodear de
músicos productores ingenieros jóvenes
que están ahí en esa tendencia que saben
lo que está pasando en la música y me
alimento un alimento de ellos como un
vampiro que les chupa la sangre pero no
para para pretender ser como ellos
porque algunos son bastante menores
y después llevar 20 años así que me
alimento de esa sangre ese conocimiento
de la tendencia no para pretender ser
como ellos sino para crecer a partir de
quién soy yo a mis 44 años de vida casi
17 años de carrera y mientras armó mi
octavo disco la aceptación por otro lado
es fundamental en cualquier proceso de
cambio o de reinvención aceptar quiénes
somos en nuestra totalidad con nuestras
esquinas más oscuras incluso sin juicio
y sin culpa porque el juicio la culpa
solamente tienen cabida si fuésemos
procesos estáticos pero como no lo somos
no tienen cabida aquí aceptar nuestra
vulnerabilidad es tal vez el ejercicio
de mayor fortaleza que existe oírnos y
levantar la mano cuando queremos guía o
pedimos ayuda es el terreno más firme
para enfrentar un proceso de cambio como
el que estamos viviendo verdad y el
último concepto una especie de bono
extra que en esta carta de navegación
personal
es la pertinencia a partir de ahora lo
que yo haga o lo que yo diga cómo
impacta mi entorno cómo impacta al mundo
porque tiene un impacto tendemos a creer
que no importa lo que hacemos porque
somos una persona entre billones de
habitantes del planeta pero no es así si
tiene un impacto lo que yo haga tiene un
impacto lo que haga una persona tiene un
impacto y este virus es un ejemplo claro
de ello lo que lo que le pasa a una
persona impacta a miles impacta a
millones entonces pensemos bien cuál
queremos que sea el impacto de nuestras
acciones
hay días en los que me cuesta un poco
más entrar al mundo y no perder la fe y
hay días en los que la vida es de
fugarse que no parece haber una razón de
ser que hay días en los que me duelen
más hay días en los que no aguanto más
hay días en los que no soy capaz tú
tienes esos días corazón es que te pido
por favor que no me sueltes
hay días en que nos sentimos breves o
seas de nuestra piel días en que tocó
fondo hay días en que voy volando al
viento con un trozo de papel días en que
no abre dispongo te pido por favor que
en esos días corazón tú no me sueltes
quédate cerquita porque mi silencio
grita que aunque nunca te lo admita por
tu vida que es bendices que a mí el alma
se me agitar y yo te pido por favor que
no me sueltes si tú quédate si puedes sé
qué quieres no si debes yo te pido que
me esperes mientras todo se resuelve si
te cansa el pasivo elvis y yo te pido
por favor que no me sueltes
y
hay días en que nos sentimos presos este
no está bien días en que tocó
no hay días en que voy volando al viento
con un trozo de papel un día sintiendo
respondo te pido por favor que en esos
días corazón tú no me sueltes
[Música]